bonjour monsieur fernandez et merci
d'être en direct pour rt france alors de
nicolás maduro espère bien reprendre le
contrôle de l'assemblée nationale qui
est tenu par son rival
one way ball présidents autoproclamés at
il des chances d'obtenir la majorité
sachant que l'opposition boycotte le
scrutin
oui le l'issue de ce scrutin ne laisse
pas de place au doute
la majeure partie vous en partie de
l'opposition a décidé de ne pas
participer au scrutin il a eu du
suspense jusqu'à il ya peu de temps
mais s'agissant moins deux de ses
composantes aujourd'hui on estime que le
le gouvernement devrait les forces qu'il
soutienne gagner cette élection avec
assez facilement voter ou ne pas voter
c'est la question qui divise aujourd'hui
les vénézuéliens le pot de participation
cette véritable enjeu de ce scrutin
tout à fait le problème effectivement
que l'on observait et cela c'est que là
il n'y a plus de lien entre la
légitimité légale d'une élection et sa
légitimité politique dans la mesure où
une grande partie de population ne fait
plus confiance aux institutions et donc
une large partie d'entre elles devrait
s'abstenir et une grande partie des os
et des partis d'opposition et en
particulier les parties conforme là n é
dellal a appelé à ne pas participer au
scrutin
le résultat de ces législatives
sera-t-il décisif tant sur le plan
intérieur qu'international ce mouvement
non j'ai envie de vous dire non dans la
mesure aujourd'hui où là la
préoccupation principale des
vénézuéliens réside dans la situation
économique du pays et que celle ci
malgré une politique peu lisible de la
part du gouvernement celle ci cette la
catastrophe économique et la chute du
pipe de plus de moitié aujourd'hui
découlent principalement des sanctions
de la part des états unis
j'aimerais presque vous dire que
l'élection la plus importante concernant
le venezuela était celle qui a lieu aux
états unis il ya quelques semaines les
temps que les sanctions contre le
l'économie vénézuélienne économie
pétrolière et son système financier
perdureront il sera quasiment impossible
au venezuela de sortir de la crise
économique qui
ce sera sa population et donc de pouvoir
être réellement à la réponse en jeu que
qui selon la population sont sa
principale préoccupation
justement l'arrivée de joe biden à la
maison blanche le 20 janvier prochain
vous pensez que les choses pourraient
changer les relations pour échanger
entre les états unis et le venezuela où
est ce que les américains vont
finalement gardé leur même direction
leur même administration vis-à-vis de ce
pays alors sur la forme on peut
s'attendre peut-être un changement de
ton des fenêtres des négociations qui
pourraient s'ouvrir mais je pense qu'il
faut rester prudent et je suis sûr que
legault avait des zones aujourd'hui est
très prudent sur les conséquences que
pourrait avoir le changement de régime
aux états unis et on n'a de toute façon
observé depuis le gouvernement bush en
passant par obama et jusqu'à trump une
deux une un dénominateur commun entre
tous ces gouvernements sur le lot
l'hostilité contre le régime et le
gouvernement vénézuélien et le chinese
man général il faut pas oublier que joe
biden était le vice-président du
gouvernement obama qui viennent avait
décrété que le venezuela constituer une
menace contre la sécurité des états unis
et par voie de conséquence avait ouvert
la voie à toute une série de sanctions
qui frappe au but le venezuela
donc je ne pense pas qu'au venezuela on
s'attendre aujourd'hui à une
amélioration substantielle de la
relation entre ces deux pays même si
effectivement des canaux de deux des
voies de communication ou de négociation
pourrait s'ouvrir une mission qui qui ne
va pas résoudre on va dire la crise
économique que traverse le pays mais ce
qu'elle pourra permettre au moins de
trouver une certaine stabilité politique
c'est l'enjeu est effectivement réside
dans une sorte de comment dire de de ce
statut ou au venezuela qui entre
polarisation politique et sociale forte
d'une part et d'autre part qu'ils
économique tragique pour la population
ce statu quo est appelée à durer à mon
sens et donc on peut s'attendre à ce que
la population quelque part des n'est
malheureusement
habitué à cet état de fait c'est le en
tout cas ce que l'on observe aujourd'hui
dans le non non non le discours des
villes et de liens c'est que on ne sait
toujours pas quand est-ce que le pays
touchera le fond d'apprendre que sa
situation économique
le venezuela pourrait très bien être
amené à ouvrir une situation instable
dans les prochaines années tout comme se
trouvait dans la même situation d'ici
cinq à dix ans il n'ya plus d'horizon
politique aujourd'hui pour une grande
partie des vénézuéliens et c'est un
petit peu ce qui explique que hormis une
frange militante de part et d'autre
au venezuela la plus grande partie
population elle est plutôt que dans un
oeuf dans une sorte de lassitude
vis-à-vis de désastres ces institutions
de la vie politique une éolienne
mais ce alors je pèse mes mots ce qui
pousse ceux qui n'ont n'a même pas non
plus a qualifié de dictature le
venezuela n'est pas une dictature c'est
plutôt une démocratie qui fonctionne mal
merci beaucoup en tout cas fabrice
fernandes d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes un
fin diplomate venezuela et consultants